republicans are reacting to catanje
brown jackson's nomination to the
supreme court and to the war in ukraine
at the conservative political action
conference or cpac the annual gathering
is also seen as a launching pad for
presidential hopefuls in the 2024 race
but tonight attendees will hear from the
2020 republican presidential nominee cbs
news chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa
robert costa is covering cpac in orlando
florida bob good morning
good morning michelle former president
trump is scheduled to speak here at cpac
tonight in orlando but cpac is about
more than former president trump it's
also a snapshot of the republican party
inside the convention halls where party
leaders mingled with talk radio hosts
and college republicans the war in
ukraine is stirring up new debate on
foreign policy there is plenty of sharp
criticism of president biden and broad
support for the embattled ukrainian
people these are people that are
basically saying we refuse to be putin
slaves
we refuse to live under tyranny we're
prepared to give our life and die for it
but there is no republican consensus
about how exactly the u.s should respond
we actually need to decrease our troop
presence in europe and the party is
still strongly influenced by trump in
recent days he has called putin smart
and savvy on ukraine drawing rebukes
from democrats and a muted gop response
there are lots of things president trump
says that i wouldn't say and his
rhetoric i with some regularity disagree
with but if you actually look at policy
who actually stood up to russia it's not
even close
possible 2024 hopefuls are navigating
all of these dynamics at times uneasily
balancing trump and the base with their
own views on putin a word you used in a
recent interview respect with regard to
putin has generated a lot of attention
i'm sure you're aware of it why did you
choose to use that word because i have
respect for him
because he is shrewd because he is
cunning you can see it
he's now invaded a nation and born
almost no cost from an administration
that is supine in the face of this
threat you know i've been fighting
communists since i was a teenager
i've been crushing them everywhere i've
gone my entire life i want to crush
vladimir putin too but you don't pretend
right you don't pretend that your enemy
is weak when he's not you don't pretend
he's dumb when he's smart i think he's
an evil man he's an evil man who craves
power and he only respects strength and
president biden's been weak and that is
why we have the consequences we see
playing out today in ukraine
many democrats have criticized
republicans here for being too close in
their rhetoric to russian president
vladimir putin white house press
secretary jenn saki says the president
has put maximum pain on russia in recent
days but it's president trump who will
speak here later today his sources
sources close to him tell me he has no
regrets about his comments on putin and
he's going to take a usual uh
traditional line on russia and not get
into any criticism of the russian
president back to you interest
interesting to hear that robert uh a lot
of people following that so closely and
by the way bob uh extending you a very
warm welcome as i'm told this is your
inaugural cvs saturday morning hit i was
honored to be on with you on red and
blue for your inaugural streaming hit
and here we are once again welcome
welcome thanks so much elaine i
appreciate it
all right talk to you soon